thank you very much it's a real pleasure
to be here for this debate the motion
for the debates reads the battle for the
countryside Britain should re wild its
uplands which can seem to some may be an
arcane subject not to me however nor I
imagine to you and certainly not to our
speakers the challenge that you face is
to choose between competing options and
sharply contrasting visions not only
about the future character of a great
swathe of Britain's most treasured
landscape but more broadly a character
that goes to the heart of a wider debate
about the environment we'll hear about
growing threats to biodiversity about
the role of farming prospects for
tourism about local livelihoods and
agricultural subsidies about deep-rooted
communities and cultures about heritage
and of course about landscape and beauty
in short the debate is about her a
number of very important dilemmas that
are delineated if you like in the
uplands but have much wider significance
for all of us who have a care for the
future now to the format you've already
voted on the motion when you came in and
in the moment we're going to hear the
opening speeches from our four principal
speakers after that I'll announce the
result of that first vote in which
you've just participated then it's your
turn your questions which I am sure will
generate further debate between our
panelists our speakers and after that
the protagonists will deliver short
summing up speeches which we then
deliver the final vote on and that is
where we come to our first speaker for
the motion george mommy-o Guardian
journalist environmental campaigner
author of some my totted up some 16
books on that issue of the environment
and related questions
his most recent federal rewilding the
land sea and human life sets out his
vision for a new way of living by
re-engaging with nature in a positive
way
he recently incidentally helped to found
the charity rewilding Britain which
seeks to redefine people's relationship
to the living natural world George Monck
meow
thank you if you take a look at a
satellite map of Britain and Europe
you'll see something very peculiar in
the rest of Europe you'll see more or
less what you would expect to see that
the lowlands where the soil is good and
the climate is benign are farmed and as
a result they're mostly treeless and the
uplands where the soil is poor and the
climate is harsh aren't generally
forested because it's not worth farming
there you look at Britain and you'll see
something very odd the lowlands as you
would expect to largely bear but the
uplands are even barrer above about 200
metres trees are a rarity here as a
result while the European average is 37%
tree cover in the UK it's 13% the places
where you would expect to find the great
wildlife refuges the functioning
ecosystems are almost completely
stripped of what was once there there
are many parts of the British uplands
where you can walk all day and see a few
crows and a couple of Pippins
is this because of geography because of
altitude because of climate not at all
our uplands were once covered in a rich
mosaic of habitats dominated by
temperate rainforest teeming with
wildlife now they're stripped depleted
depleted of soil depleted of their water
holding capacity so that the rain
flashes off causing floods downstream
depleted of wildlife but also
spectacularly depleted of human life
our uplands are among the emptiest parts
of temperate Europe because the
activities there do not support anything
but a handful of jobs and very poor
income something very strange has
happened in this country what is it
and the answer bizarrely is taxpayers
money the reason for the difference
between Britain and Europe is that the
European Union bizarrely and
disgracefully pays people by the hectare
for owning land the more land you own
the more you get paid it's about the
most regressive redistribution of public
money on earth today and on the whole in
the rest of Europe land holdings are
relatively small average land holdings
in the UK are much bigger than the
European average as a result you can
make a living by harvesting subsidies
and that by and large is what is going
on in the uplands when you look at an
upland landscape what you see is what
appears to be sheep farming but in
economic terms the sheep are ornamental
the actual industry is collecting public
money sheep farming everywhere in the
uplands in fact all Hill farming in the
UK makes a loss it cannot pay for itself
because the climate is so harsh the soil
is so poor that productivity is
remarkably low according to my estimates
which are the only thing going at them
because there's no official figures and
no academic figures sheep in the uplands
of Britain occupy roughly four million
hectares that's more or less the same
amount of land as all the arable and
horticultural land in Britain and yet
they produce one percent of our food
that four million hectares incidentally
is more than twice the area of the
entire built environment all the towns
the roads the airports everything sheep
in this country have done more
ecological damage than all the building
that has ever happened here they are a
fantastically effective means of
scouring the land they seek out tree
seedlings is their favorite food
they then seek out all the other edible
plants leaving behind the coarse and
wiry unpalatable
grasses and in doing so they empty the
ecosystem of its richness of its
diversity of the habitats that animals
and the other plants make yourself it's
not just cheap in fairness those parts
of the uplands of aren't sheep wrecked
are trashed by grouse roots or by
overstock deer doing very similar things
and the pity of it all is that this
incredible swath of destruction is
employing such a pitiful number of
people people who desperately need
decent livelihoods people who
desperately need to be able to stay on
the land in Rory's lake district the
average age of farmers is now 58 and
rising rapidly the young people aren't
sticking with it because even with the 3
billion pounds of subsidies we're paying
they cannot make a decent living and
this is before brexit are we going to
continue after brexit to pay 3 billion
pounds a year for environmental
destruction the equivalent of the NHS
deficit somehow I doubt it
things are changing they're changing
already and I say let's embrace this
change and make a virtue of it and make
a virtue of it through rewilding the
mass restoration of ecosystems not in
all the uplands by any means but in some
large areas making wonderful thrilling
places that we can step into almost on
our doorsteps to experience a
magnificent encounters with wildlife in
ecosystems that we currently travel
halfway around the world to have and
what examples all over Europe from the
Danube Delta to the fogger ash mountains
in in Romania to the de Heiser of
Portugal to the Vella bits in Croatia
wherever you look rewilding is employing
more people and generating more income
than the traditional industries than
were there that were there before it's
bringing back not only a resurgence of
wild
but a resurgence of human life and the
schools and the shops and the chapels
and most importantly the pubs that were
closing before are reopening communities
are coming back to life on the back of a
nature based economy because what you
discover all over the world is that
people will pay and pay well to engage
with nature and to have magnificent
experiences and everywhere in these
places we see a great resurgence of
wildlife guiding of Rangers of of
bed-and-breakfast of catering of
transport of all the associated
activities because this is something
without even any subsidies can actually
provide decent employments it repeals
the land as well as our rewilding the
land the two things go together Rory
made a charming video just a couple of
days ago saying it's got a D people
everything the Sheep is the biggest
agent of dispossession there's ever been
in the British countryside it drove the
Highland Clearances it drove the
enclosures in Utopia Thomas More says
your sheep that was want to be so mild
and tame and so small eater is now as I
hear tell become so great a devourer and
so wild that it swallows down the very
men themselves and eats them up and what
he was talking about thank you thank you
very much
on behalf of Thomas More I thank you
what he was talking about was the
enclosure driven by the wool industry
which still to this day has left the
countryside empty of people why don't we
see this well perhaps because of two and
a half thousand years of ovine
propaganda beginning with the pastoral
poetry of theocracies in ancient Greece
picked up by the Roman poets picked up
by the Elizabethan poets Spencer Marlowe
Shakespeare and the rest picked up there
up by the romantics and now every Sunday
night on BBC TV the BBC BBC was only
keener and cheap it would be illegal and
as a result of this we are blinded to
the realities of what is going on that
this agency has strict human life and
wildlife from our land but we could have
a totally different economy coupled with
a totally different
ecology I envisage large areas of the
land where we can see a revival of
highly depleted wildlife like wild cats
like capitalist a return of missing
wildlife everything from pelicans to
links from cranes to beavers that where
we can enhance our lives and the people
who host us through reviving their
economies can enhance theirs ladies and
gentlemen why would we not embrace this
change why would we retain a failed
model why would we be stuck in a past
which cannot deliver for the future I
ask you to approve the motion thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
and now our first speaker against the
motion is minute battle she's president
of the NF u first woman president
incidentally represents agriculture and
horticulture in England and Wales she
runs a talented sheep family farm in
Berkshire where she farms cattle sheep
and arable and she co-founded two
campaigns amongst other things that
she's done ladies in beef and the great
British beef week minute batters
well I just want to start by thanking
you so much for inviting me to speak
here tonight many of you will have seen
there's been a lot of engagement on
Twitter about why is this event taking
place in London I actually think it's
really good to have an event like this
in London I think we need to see far
more of the countryside's coming to the
town engaging showing what we are doing
but I'm very much the odd one out here
tonight because I hadn't realised that
Rory had actually written a book my
other partners in crime here or not have
written several books and I haven't
written any books I am first and
foremost a farmer and I might be
president at the nfu now but my earliest
childhood memory was of wanting to farm
I grew up with parents who farmed in
partnership with my current landlords
and I could remember from a very very
early age having a a complete love of
cows and an absolute determination to
farm where I had grown up that wasn't
going to be possible though because we
didn't have succession tenancy and I
grew up with a father who was very
adamant that women did not go into
farming and of course the more you're
told you can't have something in my case
the the more I wanted it and the more
determined I was to have it so in 1998 I
took on a very derelict farm with no
fences no buildings a few fairly
derelict suckling cows and every single
friend
I knew saying for goodness sake don't do
it you have a successful career don't
I've never for one minute regretted that
decision I made and I guess the point I
want to get across to you tonight is
farmers are experts in their own field I
would acknowledge that the c.a.p has
taken them down many a wrong alley I
would acknowledge that we can do things
much better and I hope I'll get that
point across to you but for me
pharming mean to me you cannot beat
seeing new life come into this world
seeing a calf born sing a lamb born it
is for me the most uplifting feeling
that I can see and helping new life come
into the world as I had to do two weeks
ago I always took the decision in this
job that I would work every weekend I
wouldn't have any help of course all the
problems are at weekends so we had a
breach carving that's when a calf is
coming backwards just as bad as it is
with a human baby it has to come out
fast pull the calf out not breathing
massage its heart open its mouth breathe
into its mouth and eventually it takes
its first gulp of air I tell you there's
no better feeling tonight the motion the
battle for the countryside Britain
should re wild its uplands I'm delighted
to see our distinguished Secretary of
State firstly still in his job thank
goodness and Michael Gove had the sense
to talk about health and harmony battles
this is nature this is the countryside
battles have no place in that field
I bought look from the back they look
the same don't they Penguin Books
ferrule by George mom Bo and the
Shepherd's life by James Reeb banks two
great books and a lot of tonight's
debate will be around whether you're in
the feral camp or whether you're in the
James Reeb Banks camp I hope tonight I
can do James Reed banks justice and
bring to life the uplands firstly can I
just ask how many farmers that are in
the audience could you just put your
hands up so not many but how many
uplands farmers okay so we literally I
think I can count them on one hand I
think there are five danny's that is
quite important there are only five
upland farmers in the room and it is
their lives that we are talking about so
how many upland farmers are there are
there 100 other 500 George talks about
them in fairly disposable terms actually
in England there are 6,500 upland
farmers so the uplands are
the first instance they are owned they
are cultural landscapes they are small
farmed landscapes and they were agreed
by consensus in the 1940s so how many
people go to the uplands to this barren
wilderness
well actually 70 million people visit
the uplands every year now many of you
will know the late districts many of you
will know X X more it's like comparing
apples with pears they are incredibly
diverse in what they have to offer but
ultimately 70 million people go there
and they hold 86 percent of open access
so that is why people go there because
they can go they can see the beauty my
friend Andrea was there recently and I
said to Andrea I'm doing this debate
with George he's gonna be tough he's
gonna want things different he's gonna
want it rewilding he's gonna say there's
a couple of crows and no trees and
that's it come back and tell me what is
there so she came back and she said well
firstly I'm covered in bites all over
for the invertebrates that have been
biting me on my two-week camping trip it
is a life she said especially in the
mornings it is a live with birdsong she
came back and she said it had been the
best holiday she'd ever had so those 70
million people that visit let's break
this down George talks about subsidy
most governments across the world
support agriculture in one way or
another because they want to see food
stay at a consistent price we have a new
opportunity to build a new structure for
the UK based on what we have to offer
and how important that is but 70 million
people and we have 230 million pounds
worth of public funding that is going
into the uplands so if you break that
down that is less than three pounds 30
per person per visit now I don't about
you where you live and where you parked
your cars
I can't even park my car for one hour in
the city centre car park now you can go
to the uplands I think that is a
phenomena
return on investment for less than three
pounds 30 per person and of course
support is there to provide things that
the market can't deliver on so 70% of
our water comes from the uplands 28 out
of the 38 dragonfly species are in the
uplands now last week I was in Holland
talking to the Dutch farmers and I had
the chance to ask them about the east of
our departing project it's been a
rewilding project just east of Amsterdam
it's 5,000 hectares in total and it was
an area of land that as George says in
his book it's a good idea and it'll be
interesting to see what happened and
that is how it started as a a good idea
and we'll see what happened well it is
an absolute disaster zone the trees have
gone the wildlife has gone and the
animals that were introduced are
starving so that is cattle horses and
deer the farmers union over there said
farmers would be put in prison for what
has happened and for the Dutch families
in Amsterdam instead of taking their
children there to enjoy the blue tea and
the splendor they take their children
there at weekends loaded up with hay to
feed the animals the point I'm trying to
make is you can't just stand back and
hand over to nature the point I made at
the beginning about farmers being
experts we have to manage the landscape
the UK whether we like it or not is a
farmed landscape and the uplands have
been farmed for millennia now I couldn't
come here tonight as a lowland farmer
without speaking to my great friend in
Northumberland Graham Dixon now I took
the chair of the Environment Agency up
to meet Graham and Graham bowled up to
me and he said oh you all that woman
from the Environment Agency and I said
no I'm not I'm your president of the nfu
and I thought oh no here we go another
grumpy upland farmer and you know what
he gave me
phenomenal presentations so he's
finishing 2000 lambs for M&S he stopped
the village of El Winton flooding with
his natural flood risk management
measures and he's the farm behind the
five point sheep nameless plan that was
launched three years ago at the Oxford
farming conference to say Emma was
bowled over by him is an understatement
and he is now working in partnership
with the Environment Agency rolling out
the natural flood mismanagement measures
that they are delivering and I said to
Graham I said Graham if this was your if
you view standing here tonight what do
you really think we have to offer he
said does everybody in that room want
high welfare nutrient-dense safe
affordable food do they want that I
would say yes do they recognize farmers
role in mitigating climate change that
we can plant more trees we can do this
in a way that really really works for
everybody like I've shown at our Winton
and are we going to rebalance
Agriculture's relationship with nature
does brexit offers us an opportunity to
do things differently yes it does the
point I want to get across to you
tonight and I feel so passionate and so
worried about not landing that point
with this intelligent audiences farmers
going forwards are the solution and I
absolutely urgent tonight thank you
[Music]
our second speaker for the emotion is
mark Cocker acclaimed as an author and
as a naturalist his latest book is
called our place
can we save britain's wildlife before it
is too late the argus turned out that
our world's become increasingly
denatured bear of flowers of animals and
of birdsong and examines in the book the
threat to the British countryside posed
by agribusiness and landed estates mock
Cocker ladies and gentlemen I just want
to say a word about George mombi oh he
sent me that speech and I cannot believe
he memorized the entire thing off the
CAF and quoted accurately Thomas More's
utopia but so thank you George for a
compelling account of how and why we
should bring nature back to our uplands
I want to delve a little into two
background issues circling back on one
of the points that George made but also
offer a final reflection on the real
challenge we face in our relationship
with the rest of life in these islands
but first I want to reiterate that it's
perfectly reasonable for us here to
debate the matter in the heart of London
I raised it precisely because a number
of people have said constantly on
Twitter in the run-up to this event that
it's a subject entirely entirely for
rural communities to discuss amongst
themselves they have argued what can you
city dwellers by and large know about
the lives of distant hill farmers or the
challenges that we face what right of
you here in Westminster to reflect on
these questions well they are correct in
one sense most of us don't own or manage
land fifty-five million of us living in
towns or cities own an average of seven
one hundredths of an acre but it doesn't
mean that we don't play a part in the
administration and conduct of what
happens on the land of others because
for the last 80 years we have paid
scores of billions of pounds
landowners my money your money Jonathan
and your Secretary of State Michael Gove
and it's great to have you here three
billion of it on average every year goes
to farmers there is a perverse dimension
to this because you might assume that in
a progressive country the most needy
would be best rewarded but that isn't
how it works the biggest sums go to the
biggest landowners our largest landowner
the Duke of the clue with his two
hundred and forty four thousand acres of
Scotland was in receipt in 2016 and 17
of two million seventy five thousand
nine hundred and thirty nine eight nine
hundred and thirty eight pounds and
fifty-one Pence and the reason we give
him so much because the more land you
owned the more money you receive that
leave ring of money out of the public
purse from the ordinary citizen and even
from the poorest to the richest is
nothing less than feudalism it is unjust
it has to end but for our purposes
understanding the scale of that
financial giveaway allows us to sweep
aside the argument put forward by
farmers or their supporters that what
happens on their land is nobody but
nobody's business but theirs it is our
business we have a right to discuss it
and be involved in the future of our
land it may not be a case of insisting
that farmers must do exactly what we
want but we are completely within our
rights to discuss it and it's perfectly
okay for us to ask that things change so
why do they need to change my second
point is to clarify what subsidies
marching in lockstep with a system of
agricultural intensification have
inflicted on our country during the last
century in effect the British people
have had to endure the most radical
simplification of their country where
once there was complexity filigree
beauty and meaning there are now in
large measure uniformly engineered
engineered arable monocultures or a
rectilinear system of graze field
comprised of nothing but livestock and
grass one overlooked but fundamental
part of that simplification
what has happened to the human diversity
in those same places at the height of
subsidy driven intensification
Conservative MP Richard body judged that
we'd lost a hundred and thirty thousand
small farmers in a single generation
from the 1960s its impact on the non
human inhabitants of these islands that
comprise our countryside has been
nothing short of devastating from
England we've lost ninety-nine percent
of four million acres of flower rich
meadows in southern England large moths
have declined by 40 percent in the last
few decades three-quarters of all
British butterflies have declined in
either abundance or distribution in the
last 40 years during the 20th century we
lost a million ponds all our amphibians
and reptiles are threatened as a
consequence these figures only glanced
at the real impact which these losses
carry they're just numbers they don't
express the individual heartache which
is inflicted on millions of people tens
of thousands all over the country so I
want to tell you a little bit about how
the decline of birds impacted upon me
this is what intensification and
subsidies have done to the places where
I was born in Buxton in Derbyshire
precisely the kind of area where we
could do something other than over graze
it with sheep when I was a child of 12
to 18 this was a landscape of lapwings
and gray partridges snipe and Reid
buntings Woodcock's perform their
fabulous roading displays over our
garden in the evenings and just up the
road in the woods above where I lived
I'd see wood Warblers singing in the
beaches cuckoo sang every spring morning
there were red starts and tree pivots
spotted fly catchers and common
sandpipers around the reservoir they
were part of my daily life most moving
and I remember it vividly a moment in
1972 when I first saw as a 12 year old
boy a ringed goozle a migrant upland
thrush with a plaintive wild voice the
bread in the gritstone cloths since then
all of those birds that I have mentioned
have gone completely or remained merely
as occasional
visitors as part of a red-letter day
whenever they're sighted they've not
just gone from Buxton and from my daily
life those species have declined
nationwide by between 60 to 95 percent
all of them every single one overall in
the last 40 years we know we have lost
44 million breeding birds that's what
happens when you strip nature down to
the very stump that's what happens as a
consequence of a subsidy driven
industrial farming regime over 80 years
that pursues only production and treats
land as a as a medium for tax breaks or
for profit land is so much more than
that nature is at the heart of our
spiritual lives it's a safety valve for
our mental well-being it's the theater
for all forms of physical exercise it's
a key driver of our cultural life place
our special places are at the heart of
our sense of identity nature is part of
our daily joy these are the things it
does for us other than provide food
which is absolutely essential of course
but it also provides home and life for
50 to 80 thousand other species than our
own they have a right to live here to
plant trees mosses ferns Fox toads bees
butterflies moths spiders birds mammals
funghi liver Worth's
yet the state of nature report of 2016
the most authoritative audit of British
wildlife ever undertaken judged England
to be the 28th most denatured country on
earth how bad does it have to get before
our opponents admit that things cannot
go on it is time to put something back
into the land other than ourselves I'm
gonna close by clip by telling a very
short anecdote a reader of my book wrote
to me recently I'm about what happened
on his Norfolk alakh allotment many
species of plant and associated insect
pollinators like the disturbed habitats
associated with hand-done crops
hand-dug crops and the organic
allotments are great for while
this chap had some wildlife friendly
plants on his allotment and he received
a letter from the allotment committee
telling him and that he had to stream
and spray what they called weeds on his
plot and if he didn't comply they would
take the plot off him and use his
deposit
to spray it for him this leads me back
to our motion about rewilding the
uplands we can forget the reintroduction
of wolves and the conversion of sheep
pasture to climax woodland if we can't
even allow a little bit of space for a
few flowers important and full of
extraordinary potential it may be to
rewilding z-- it is not enough it is
only a part of the picture because what
we need is something more fundamental
that takes account of wolves and
allotment flowers alike we need more of
the fifty to eighty thousand species
which share these islands with it
we need more nature in the uplands but
we need it everywhere we need it in our
cities in our back gardens in our civic
spaces what is rewilding but allowing
more nature to co-exist alongside us we
should realize that real rewilding is
not something that happens out there
only in remote bits of the countryside
far from here it is something we can all
do and share it is a further reason why
we should hold a debate here because it
is as relevant in this place as it is in
Rory's Cumbria so when you vote for it
tonight recall that it's something in
which you can and should participate and
if you're not willing to do it on your
patch then don't expect upland farmers I
have faith however that you will share
my contention that we cannot go on as we
have we have to change and we must
restore nature to this denuded country
if we don't we will rob future
generations of what Italy it means to
live fully in connection with the rest
of life I ask you to approve the motion
[Music]
our second speaker against the motion is
Rory Stewart the Conservative MP for
Penrith and the Border's Eden and the
border here he therefore is the MP for
the constituency in England with the
largest percentage of up clans in 2018
he was made justice minister and as we
speaks far as I know he's still Justice
Minister before that he was the Minister
of State is that true just checking for
those Minister of State for African
before that he was Minister for the
environment and Rural Affairs at Defra
indeed after the awful floods of
2015-2016 he was the flood envoi for
Cumbria and Lancashire overseeing the
recovery efforts there he is passionate
about the borderlands between England
and Scotland which you can discover if
you read his book the marches are
borderland journey between England and
Scotland his most recent book Rory
Stuart's
well thank you very much indeed um
this is a very very serious debate and
although we've had a lot of very
entertaining speeches it is important to
try to clarify what the differences are
between our positions so I'm going to be
a little bit boring to begin right the
key point about this debate is it is
about rewilding the uplands it is not
about whether or not we care about
nature in Britain so we need to begin
absolutely by acknowledging that a lot
of what George and Mark have said is
100% absolutely true there has been a
terrible loss in Britain particularly
since 1940s since the Second World War
in terms of beauty in terms of wildlife
in terms of meaning a lot of that has
unfortunately been driven through the
40s 50s and 60s by agricultural policy
long before anybody joined the European
Union an enormous amount of damage has
also been done by forestry plantation
damage has been done by cities damage
has also been done by abandonment of
land all of this together means that
everything that George and Mark have
said in terms of environmental damages
absolutely corrects and I'm not here in
any way it's a challenge there erudition
their knowledge the question is how do
we respond to this and in particular do
we respond to this in terms of this
motion which is and is only about
rewilding the uplands now that means
that I have to deal with two quite
different people here right a one of
them of course is George now it's
extremely
difficult arguing against a man of such
immense hutzpah erudition able to quote
Thomas More off the top of his head who
talks sometimes than Guardian articles
about his delight at the notion of
reintroducing the Asian elephant on the
Rhino only to change positions and
suggests he doesn't really mean that he
means the wool from the Lynx who talks
about creating two Serengeti Zin Europe
and then shifts back to saying perhaps
Britain is too small I ought to know how
difficult it is to argue against someone
like this I ought to know how difficult
it is to try to make small detailed
reasonable arguments against someone
like this I worked for Boris Johnson now
mark on the other hand is making a
different kind of argument mark is
making a very very powerful argument for
the British environment but very little
of his argument if you listen to it
carefully was about rewilding or about
rewilding the uplands he talked with
immense passion and conviction about the
loss of butterflies many of those
butterflies would not flourish in the
closed canopy temperate rainforests that
George mom bo is imagining appearing
through a rewilding uplands many of the
species which have been evoked by Mark's
powerful speech and this might even
extend to lap wings and curl you may
also not flourish in a close forested or
even scrubbed environment it's also true
that much of the loss that he's talking
about in terms of ponds and a lot of the
arguments he's making around industrial
agriculture simply barely apply to the
uplands of England that industrial
architecture enshrined in the
agriculture I quote the words that he's
using he's talking about arable
monoculture he's talking about
rectilinear pastoral systems these are
simply not characteristic of the upland
in fact most of the land that George is
concerned about most of the uplands that
he's concerned about and with reason
then he has strong arguments here most
of that is simply not rectilinear it
hasn't received large amounts of
fertilizer it hasn't received large
amounts of pesticide effectively the
claim that George is making is that the
uplands have been over stopped but
that's not the only claim that he's
making and I'm going to be a little bit
boring just for 45 seconds to try to
point out why it's quite important to
focus on the claims that are actually
being made and I'm sorry if I'm sounding
a little bit legalistic here in that
amazingly charming exposition by George
he began with a great fact he produced a
great vision Europe in general has 37%
woodland cover Britain by contrast has
only 13% and what is responsible for
this
it is subsidies and in particular the
subsidies of the European Union what is
the problem with this argument the
problem with this argument is that
woodland cover today in Britain is
larger than any time since the 14th
century the entire amount of woodland
cover in Britain in 1900 was 3% would
George like to explain exactly how we
went from 3% coverage in 1900 to 13%
coverage today and somehow it's all the
faults of European Union subsidies
shades of Boris Johnson begin to appear
in my mind right
and the reason why I'm doing this is
that it is quite important to understand
what's really going on and it's quite
important to understand the kind of
solutions that George is proposing not
mark because as I say mark is basically
making an argument that I 100% agree on
mark should be on this side of the table
Mark is arguing for good environmental
restoration projects and in particular
he's put a huge focus on the
catastrophic damage to our lowlands the
uplands ironically contain most of the
triple-s eyes in Britain it is exactly
because there has not been intensive
agriculture in the uplands that we now
end up in the perverse situation that
environmentalists are trying to argue
for the displacement of farmers from the
uplands as a reward for the fact that
those farmers did not trash the
environment in the same way that the
lowlands were trashed instead of turning
around 180 degrees the basis of George's
argument George has stated in a Guardian
article 2013 that there are three
reasons why we should concentrate on the
uplands number one it is unproductive
land number two that it is far from
cities and number three that it is
sparsely populated those are exactly the
three reasons why we should be focusing
on environmental projects in the
lowlands that fertile productive land is
far more capable of generating
biodiversity the key example of the kind
of rewilding we should be doing in this
country and by rewilding of course I
don't mean the visions of the
Yellowstone National Park that George
sometimes tongue-in-cheek evokes of
wolves and Lynx's and great romping
herbivores Serengeti is in fact what's
happening in Knepp in Sussex at the
moment a really strong example of how
taking three and a half thousand acres
of lowland fawn can deliver species such
as the nightingale such as the turtle
dove which of course do not live in the
uplands
that loss of the nightingale has
absolutely nothing to do with the
uplands again it should be close to
cities and close to populated areas
because the natural capital value lies
partly as George implies in humans
getting into that landscape far more
health benefits will accrue to the
populations if we did and this is my
radical proposal for you to take on
these radical proposals if weary while
did the Greenbelt right if we planted
trees all the way around London then the
benefits would be extraordinary
schoolchildren would get out into that
environment the health benefits of
walking in that environment would follow
the air quality benefits that would
follow from foresting the Greenbelt in
terms of nitrogen dioxide and sulfur
dioxide emissions in London would be
astonishing doing it in the uplands
achieves none of these benefits and
insofar as there is a population in the
uplands it is because of something I
wish to finish on the fundamental point
is firstly that these upland farmers are
people who live there who own that land
who have rights and who are working
unbelievably hard day and day out to
preserve it but finally that the
landscape that they are preserving is
the landscape we dream of when we fight
on the Western Front that landscape of
wild uplands and pasture of sheep and
dry stone walls embodies not just
history but meaning which is central to
our identity thank you very much indeed
[Music]
you've heard the principal arguments for
and against and in a moment it's your
opportunity to raise any questions that
you like with our speakers but before
that you will want to know I'm sure what
the vote was before we started for the
notion rewilding 61% against 13 percent
undecided 26% see what happens when we
have the final vote so who is going to
kick off with questions and thoughts
from the floor we've got one down here
number one I'd like to know if the panel
agree that in order to reduce the worst
impacts of climate change we need a lot
more trees to absorb the carbon dioxide
which is driving climate change as
recommended by the zero carbon Britain
report okay I'm gonna hold that and take
a lot more trees is that question to
deal with climate change up the back the
number four so yeah I'm wondering like
if we can have a bit of the best of both
worlds some research that's come out the
University of Exeter shows that the
presence of beavers on land well a pair
of beavers over five years built 15 dams
in an enclosure site and they trap 200
tons of sediment coming off farmlands
well the surrounding lands 70% of that
soil was farmland soil they also reduced
phosphate flow by 1/4 and nitrates by
1/3 there they seem to have this great
role in buffering aquatic so what do you
what are you asking so I'm wondering
like if the sort of well as well as that
effect they can buffer against flooding
in the uplands so surely is there not a
role for beavers in rewilding the
uplands but also supporting
farming communities there and the
impacts they may be having okay
trees and beavers the role of the role
of trees minute first of all look I
mentioned it with what Graham Dixon had
said I mean yes we can plant more trees
we've actually got more trees now than
we had a hundred years ago and in the
last five years the Woodland Trust have
worked with farmers and planted a
million trees so it isn't just about
planting trees mitigating the challenges
of climate change is a huge job as
custodians of seventy percent of the
land I think farmers have a massive role
and really are up for taking on that
challenge and delivering on it but yes
absolutely supportive of more trees in
the right place and as part of a
cohesive catchment based approach
because the point being catchments are
incredibly different farming systems are
different and you've got to work with
the catchments in order to get the
biggest bang for buck for climate change
there's absolutely support you're saying
in the right place George Rory made the
point earlier it's 3% in 1900 of the
land was covered with trees now 13%
which suggests an increase how honest
earlier you talked about a protein you
said some large areas should be rerouted
put those two things together how much
more woodland cover do you want to see
or at remote well on Rory's point the
point about Europe is that the woodland
has recovered in the uplands then most
of European countries were also bad and
there's been a massive woodland recovery
you go to Slovenia you go to Italy you
go to Switzerland you go to so many
European countries you will see forests
where there were not forests before a
hundred years ago that has not happened
here and it's happened for the reasons I
outlined what percentage would you get -
if you get your way you value this huge
error I would I would like to see at
least 10% of the British uplands become
reviled it and you know I'm not talking
about a blanket rewilding by any means
but you know this is the most
appropriate place for trees to grow
because you're not displacing fertile
land which should
used for growing food and while I would
love to see more trees in the Greenbelt
as well I don't want to take vast tracts
of good food producing land out of
production I want to see it in the
places where it makes makes no sense
to be farming because you produce so
little Rory pick up on beavers the role
of beavers in protecting let me just
come back on on George and the
fundamental points about Britain is that
we have been very densely populated for
a very very long time these trees have
not disappeared from Britain recently if
you look at the uplands where I live in
the Lake District you can see from the
positioning of Romans signal stations
that this land was deforested at the
time of the Romans you can see from the
positioning of Neolithic standing stones
which relied on astronomical visions and
you can see also from pollen sampling
and from the nature of the peat that
this land was deforested a very long
time ago in fact the majority of Britain
as George Ness and as mark knows was
deforested during the Neolithic period
now the pigment is that an argument of
Bigfoot is that argument against
reforesting it's not nothing to get
reforesting it's not it's not against
reversing but it is an important fact to
register in people's mind that George is
not talking about returning to the
recent past so insofar as we care about
the history of the British landscape the
meaning embedded in that landscape in
the sense in which that landscape is the
roots and growth of our civilization so
far as we care about seeing those
Neolithic standing stones those
archaeological sites that medieval
woodland that moorland those butterflies
those birds these things are not
consistent with attempting and it would
be very difficult given the nature of
the peat to reforest the upland at the
same time this point about Europe is
simply not true the woodland cover in
Poland for example in the 18th and 19th
century was approximately 40% of the
landmass when it was 3% in Britain it is
currently in Poland at about 28
percent the story fundamentally is that
these European countries were much
wilder and insofar as scrub and trees
have returned to Europe they have
returned because of depopulation
abandonment of those areas okay okay um
mark would you pick up on the on the
Bieber question in the context of what
you were saying about the denature is
can I talk about beavers and trees but
they seem to go together quite often
don't they one way or another the first
thing to say is that of course beavers
would be part I mean the other thing too
to qualify as that Rory tried in a
fantastically skillful military maneuver
to split Georgia me oh and I applaud his
fabulous strategy that would have been a
great success in Afghanistan but doesn't
work here
I was simply fleshing out some of the
younger pinning arguments that drive
Georgia's main contention that the
uplands are the place it's the cheapest
and most meaningful part to make the
biggest impact as quickly as possible
just does anything to say about behaves
or just before you come to videos you
you in your in what you were saying you
talked about industrialized agriculture
yeah the point was made against that
that there's very little industrialized
agriculture in the uplands as opposed to
the denatured lowland is that it so does
your argument not attach more to the
lowlands that does to the uplands the
classic part of that is that when
subsidies were ply to the head of sheep
in Cumbria and Derbyshire the numbers of
sheep stopped on individual farms
rocketed and that was because the the
the subsidy paid per sheep just
increased the coffers of the sheep
farmer and so and so it was just
subsidy driven profiting regardless of
the quality and the impact on the land
so I think it was subsidy driven if it
wasn't industrialization okay to Eva's
fever I mean one of the interesting
thing is that beavers we have been
trying cautiously to reintroduce beavers
I think it's a fantastic way in which we
could manage more sustainably our
riverine environments one of the
interesting things is that the
a major drag on beaver reintroduction
has been the deep caution of farmers and
understandably there are conservative
people but you know we need to awaken
that these things can be incredibly
profitable on a whole range of things
such as climate change sediment control
flooding etc etc so yes to be this and
the other thing to say about trees class
and quickly is important ok well short
trees would come up again in the fourth
third or fourth reconquered seems the
lights are glaring at us there was a
woman with her hand up
yes dark hair yes I would like to ask
about predation probably this is
probably fit for mark I I think probably
all of us in this room are very worried
about butterflies and songbirds being on
the decline who and who is not worried
in this room about decline of
butterflies right a hundred percent of
we take it that's a good start but I
feel that farmers always get the blame
for this and particularly intensive
agriculture and something that isn't
talked about enough is predation we
worry about hedgehogs and in the
Hedgehog debate it's always about the
lack of habitat but actually very few
people mentioned that Badgers eat
hedgehogs
Badgers are a huge predator the biggest
predator songbirds Sambas are down so
severely sparrowhawks has a clue in the
name sparrowhawks eat sparrows and yeah
the RSPB only protect songs of prey okay
point taken predation mark well each
issue has to be taken on its own I mean
the other thing to say is ablute it as a
predator young blue tits in your bird
box on nothing but caterpillar larva but
the reason that songbirds have declined
or some songbirds has declined is not
the increase in sparrowhawks it's an old
chestnut all of the studies that have
been done one classic example
one classic example is the blame put on
Magpies for the loss of songbirds what
they found was that where Magpies had
exponentially increased in numbers so
had the songbirds as well they have
lived side by side for tens of thousand
millions of years and of course some
localized impacts of predation are very
negative but they aren't the problem
themselves Minette predation has huge
impact I just wanted to mark you talk
about Hettich payments it is really
naughty to do that twenty years ago
Hettich payments ended twenty years ago
you bring it up tonight to
sensationalize the argument they went 20
years ago it is not relevant to the
farming of today but the point on
predation you know I am lucky enough to
farm on the world sure Hampshire even I
can see trees a dent from the game and
Wildlife Conservancy trust and we as
farmers have come together in order to
make sure that we get the Lapwing back
in the numbers that we want on the Aven
Valley now what we have found is that we
have to put a special protection over
the Lapwing nests in order to keep the
foxes away the LAT wings are coming back
on to the avian Valley but predation is
a massive issue you know the Fox doesn't
have a natural predator the budget
doesn't have a natural predator and if
you've got ground nesting birds you've
got to have the right environment for it
and you know we have to take that
seriously you can't just say predation
isn't an issue of course it is an issue
if you're a ground nesting bird and you
lay your eggs on the ground it is not
rocket science to work out that they are
easy for de for anything to come along
and eat ok I'm going to take a number of
questions there's so many and just under
and I'm afraid we're gonna carry pick
the questions if necessary we're number
two is just there over there
my name is Mark Blackie Dourdan I live
on the edge of the Appleby's Site of
Special Scientific importance on the
edge of the York North York Moors can
you stand up oh sorry see you and we
seem to enjoy on those Moors a quality
of natural life Lapwing
curlews and ring easels mr. Mumbai er
seem to have never noticed I don't think
he's ever been on a more in his life
does he if I assure him that there is
immense wealth of wildlife and
particular ground nesting birds which
would be exterminated by his ruddy
Tremper at forest doesn't he feel
slightly sorry for English natural life
I start getting all I want George
respond to that quickly I'll bring in
down here yes well in response to both
mark and indeed Manette I would ask how
did nature cope before we came along
it must have been in a pretty dire state
before human beings turned up to look
after it George we managed them in all
the walls you talked about they were
managed before human beings turned up
okay I'm going to go sorry to go on I
can answer the question that George
poses and you you know the answer having
read Thoreau
how did nature manage before we turned
up he tells us it it managed on the
basis of giant herbivores he points out
he thinks that the black thorn is
designed to deal with the elephants he
talks about Serengeti s he talks about
apex predators and indeed the answer is
you have a trophic system the idea about
a trophic system if you want to go to
the rewilding theology here is it comes
in Yellowstone National Park it's about
cause corridors carnivores so nature
managed in this place when there were
about a hundred thousand humans living
on this island which was at about the
time of the Mesolithic period okay I
didn't predict that question the
question number one and then if I take
that and then take the question for
number four and then we'll carry on in
my questions read about the hypocrisy of
national policy in the way we all debate
about elephants and rhinos in the world
we currently have British troops in
Malawi we've got a new fund going over
to protect elephants so we essentially
guilty of conservation colonialism mark
three in that we're telling farmers in
Africa or people in Africa they can't
take that land they can't kill these
elephants but yet we have not got our
shot back in order in the United Kingdom
so surely we need to find better
policies in order to get the UK wildlife
back in order before we start going
lecturing countries overseas and they
take the question from up there number
four
just in the middle air hi hello so we've
heard a lot about the cost-benefit
analysis of responsibly restoring or
responsibly stewarding land and I accept
that it's probably the role of a
responsible government to triage public
money in terms of where and where they
spend it in the first instance I just
wonder I'm any conscious of the quote
from John 10:10 above the above the
thing and I just wonder where their
spaces and also what the mechanisms are
for preserving species biodiversity for
other than human reasons where the
spaces are where the weather space is
and what the mechanisms are for
preserving species biodiversity for
reasons other than human use and also
for the purposes we know not which we
may need in the future
and over there well number three was I
just like to make a point to both sides
of the panel about trees this obsession
with trees we have woodland and we're
also keen on rewilding and learning more
about it but closed canopy forest is not
the native way of Britain that is why it
was 3% in the past it's more now but
closed canopy tree cover does not help
rewilding or biodiversity in fact there
are various trees that can't be
supportive in closed canopy tree cover
like Oaks who need big open spaces
what we need is wetlands Meadows to stop
having Long's in our gardens and allow
grasses to grow that will provide havens
for all this other wildlife from the
bottom up insect life and straight
through ok and predators there's no way
to say that predators are something you
can get rid of it's part of it ok thank
you I want to pick either one I think we
might pick up on is this a biodiversity
question is what comes into the mind is
that there are a number of different
species that need to be protected in a
number of different ways so it's partly
the question of the space that is
available and partly the question of
what is required to protect biodiversity
in
a society where we also grow food and
who'd like to start on that it won't you
I I'd like I'd like to say something
which is that when we were in the back
room we were getting on really really
well I was slightly upset when there's
been there before Rory that started
shouts exactly about subsidies which
I'll answer later Minette but you'll
understand what I was meaning but the
critical thing here is that this is a
binary structure it's a debate between
two sides the tragedy of this kind of
processes it cannot get at the
complexity of ecosystems and truthfully
you know the lady rat mentioned the
issue of predators well and the
gentleman mentioned the issue of his
more being grateful a prism etc etc
predators are a problem we have large
populations of Fox as they are causing
enormous damage some species we can't
find a simple one-size-fits-all to
solution to ecosystem issues because
they are by their very nature incredibly
complex language itself the linear
structures of human thought struggle to
convey how these systems work so
truthfully we need to be more flexible
and and and and attentive to each
other's arguments because that's very do
you do you take the view that if if we
were more attentive rather than more
adversarial as it were say we
protagonists in this debate that you
could have some Wilding in the uplands
some upland farms that happen
biodiversity as well some lowland farms
that have the same is it compatible
because your your main of sorts was on
industrialized agriculture well is it
compatible with the production of food
on large scale farms at relatively take
into account the subsidies relatively
low cost well what I would say is that
the cheapest deal we have is to rework
that to increase our biodiversity to
fulfill our own human needs of spaces
for agriculture but also for recreation
etc spiritual cultural
NEADS the uplands of the cheapest deal
on offer but truthfully what we need is
is something everywhere and they're
different arguments in a different place
I mean look I I violently agree with
mark I'm not I'm not making a joke when
I say that he's on our side that there
are very small points of difference one
of them is it's simply not true that in
natural capital terms the uplands are
the cheapest land if you look at the
full natural capital value of lowland
land I took the example of the green
belt around London in terms of its
potential for biodiversity its potential
for air pollution its potential for
recreation its potential for human
contact the value of that land and
natural capital terms makes it a much
much better deal than up than land but
the more fundamental point which I think
we keep edging around is that land in
Britain is contested we're a very
densely populated island we are more
densely populated than India right
that's one of the reasons why this is
under so much pressure so we have to
weigh up biodiversity which is under
serious threat alongside food production
so to answer this question about
hypocrisy we need to think not just
about how much food we produce but how
much food we consume and unless like
George you become a vegan if you
continue to eat sheep but you just drive
those sheep off the British uplands all
you're doing is pushing the
environmental damage onto somebody
else's country right
those same sheep are out there they're
eating up somebody else's country
they're methane is going up into the air
and destroying the climate from somebody
else's country and the final thing is
let's not lose sight of meaning and
history in this debate because that
human landscape is as precious as
Westminster Cathedral you know there's
so many more did Barry Beckett George
glory is so right we do need to stop
eating sheep
[Laughter]
yeah they're definitely in there and
then number four and then down here and
assembly I'd love to bring everyone in
we're not gonna be able to sew up there
number four first then number one and
then the guy here whose arm is nearly
falling off it's been up for the last 27
minutes in the front row so fourth
question about 30 years ago my brothers
and I inherited 220 acres of essentially
pit props we were growing pit props for
mines my grandfather made I think a tax
based investments in the 1950s on the
edge of a major UK city for 30 years my
brothers and I have been in the planning
system and as far as I'm aware the only
way that we can re wild these these are
coniferous trees into the citrus
deciduous woodland is through some form
of planning development some sort of
housing now the problem with that is on
the edge of a city that you immediately
have the planning system attacked by
people who don't like the idea of houses
and I can understand that for the people
who live in those houses don't get to
fate because they're not in that village
at that time so I'd like to ask the
panel how can we re while on a micro
scale as individual landowners if we
need to build houses and what effect
would that have on the planning system
to resolve that problem thank you okay
thank you and Dan where was the next one
down Dan down here yeah it's down here
number one I'm a farmer I'm a member of
the NEF you and I agree with Manette
that farmers could do much to make a
difference the problem is we get a lot
your money for doing nothing and we've
got a lot your money for doing nothing
for a very long time that things have to
change
having said that farmers are very very
good
they're very very good at producing
things and nature conservation
organizations are not so there's a lot
we can learn from farmers and we should
be doing that but when it comes to
beavers I worked for B with beavers for
20 years and we talked about the uplands
one of the huge problems we have is that
there are very few trees up there and if
we're going to have beavers up there
doing all the marvelous things they do
producing a landscape which has eighty
percent greater biomass eighty percent
greater biodiversity which is literally
shrilling calling thrumming with life we
are going to have to replant those
uplands hurt the trees back and then
restore them on a scale that we're also
not used to doing because they written
we focus on small species and this is a
big animal thank you very much I'm
trying to get a bit more gender equality
than I'm able to get when I look around
at the faces so there we are number
three after we've heard this one down
here I'm confused about the the the
economic stand up suggest only places by
the economics of the question I have one
question for each side for Orion Minette
side how do you confront this apparent
fact that upland farming is an economic
can you explain that it doesn't seem to
be worth doing on the other hand for the
other side your ambitions are that there
would be a great increase in economic
value from people visiting these uplands
if they were rewilding but given the
immense economic value which is shown by
tourism in for example the lake district
is that realistic okay Rory first of all
okay on the net so the answer to this
question is that I was rather surprised
by George saying that the Upton Sardi
populated any of you who have queued in
ambleside for an hour and a half or
visited Al's water would be a bit
surprised by this my constituency is of
course more densely populated and it's
been at any time in history
and in fact all these things that George
is talking about guides archery outdoor
industries are driving our economy we
generate 2.4 billion pounds a year out
of the options as they currently stand
now how does the economics work to this
question
these subsidies asthma net points out
per farmer for delivering that to the
visitor we get about 14 million visitors
a year works out at about 3 pounds 20
per visitor for our heritage for the
contribution they make to our dry stone
walls and to that landscape which they
visit by contrast the amount of money
which you as the taxpayer give to the
Victoria and Albert Museum compared to
the number of visitors of that museum
works out at 14 pounds 50 per visitor so
the economic argument for this on the
basis of tourism is that you are getting
for about a quarter of the amounts of
money all that delights of the Lake
District preserved by those farmers I'll
come back to you Lynette we drop the
George short your economic case so there
is a two surveys one conducted by the
National Trust one by Newton rig College
both of which does a very similar thing
they showed people pictures of the Lake
District with more and more trees in
those pictures they'd photoshopped trees
in and first they asked people what is
the current state of the lake district
and almost everybody's pointed to the
pictures with more trees than there
actually are then they said what would
you like the state of the lake district
to be and overwhelmingly people chose
more trees not just than there are but
then they thought there were it's not
the subsidies and the sheep farming that
are drawing people in this crazy
equation that that money that we're
spending translates into tourism there's
no link between those things at all
except possibly a negative link Georgie
all over one since you're crocheted you
do you if to set on the statistics who
wants to stop a flow they do you accept
there are approximately 70 million and
per capita per visit that equates to
according to Manette 330 and according
he's downing the price 320 that that
that in its own terms is an economically
cheap food for the for the user they're
dividing farm subsidies by the number of
visitors now I might as well divide the
number of spiders in Britain by the
number of visitors so two things
I'm not connected winnette look Joe I
mean George talks about photo shopping
trees on I mean that is like going to my
children and say look you can Photoshop
more and more and more sweets do you
want that well yes of course they're
going to say yes you can't just I mean
it is an insult to our landscape to say
that you can photoshop it and give an
accurate picture of what is going on
George and where does your evidence case
come from is that is that you sitting
down at the family table saying does
this photo shop look better does this
one look better does this one look
better I mean where have you engagements
to find that the the other point on
profitable farming in the uplands you
know there is a challenge for the UK and
that we have a very high cost of
regulation in the UK now if you compare
us to a country like New Zealand that
hasn't chosen to regulate on on water
quality it is starting to now because it
has to we have been doing that for many
years and regulation is not free
regulation costs you can't say that
upland farmers are unprofitable there's
clear evidence if you look at the a HDV
work that shows that actually the top
25% are absolutely in profit and there
are many things and new policy we can do
to look at driving profitability not
least sorting out the supply chain and
making sure that farmers are at least
getting a fair minute I think the income
figures that one reads
suggest that the upland farmers twelve
thousand a year income way below the
minimum wage it is a very challenged way
of life in places because it is very
prescriptive as to what you can and
can't do so your average upland farming
business has got 28 breeding cows and
330 approximately breeding ewes so those
are not big farming businesses those are
small farming businesses cheap numbers
have declined a lot in the last 20 years
since the days that mark was talking
about but ultimately many of these
things can be changed but as I said to
you and it is an important point if
farmers could achieve a fair return from
the market then actually they would need
no support at all but the upland is very
fair eternal market means
pay more for your sheet beat effectively
well above a cost of production price if
you're producing anything below the cost
of production you lose money but the
appellant's also provides a vast amount
of things that the market doesn't pay
for so this is very much what Michael
Gove is focusing on and we've got to
look to the future these two keep
harping back to the past I'm going to I
get it I need a corset I really am about
to come to hook they're not going to
come to a halt before I go to the very
patient woman who's sitting there when
you've got a microphone in fact if you
already you've really nicked the
microphone well done Julia I couldn't be
chair of the uplands Alliance we bring
together farmers conservationists
academics and government and one of our
we have five components of a healthy
uplands and one of them is investment in
return for public benefit and what we
really resent is that we should read
wild the uplands because it's cheap
that's a really bad argument the reason
why upload farms are as George would say
unprofitable is because we don't pay for
the goods that they provide and if we
were to pay properly for the goods that
the uplands provide then of you would
find that we could would get much better
public benefits we all know that the cap
is not been great we all would like to
restructure it but we do need to pay
properly and those who deserve provide
most should receive accordingly you've
you've provided food for the thought as
it were of our speakers who are going to
sum up so again to leave your thought
there and I think you had five thoughts
you wanted to give us but that one I'm
afraid anyone I got time for I'm sorry
we move to the point where it would be
great if we could go on but we have to
pause we come to the point of the final
vote on the motion to remind you of that
the battle for the countryside Britain
should Rewald it's uplands just reminder
if you have already made up your mind
tear up your voting slip into and put
either for or against in the ballot box
if you haven't made up your mind
perfectly respectable position put the
whole card in the box and very soon I
will be able to tell you how you voted
but the ballot boxes are or should be
coming around we start off in two
minutes to start their cases in
sorter from how we started so we start
against the motion two minutes
Rory Stewart so fundamentally it's
important to weigh up I feel all these
very strong arguments about biodiversity
with an important understanding of who
upland farmers are and what that
landscape is and I really do appeal to
those of you in the audience who visited
the Lake District could you stick your
hands up if you visited Lake District
right thank you so I'm speaking to an
audience that knows this landscape many
of the things that make it so precious
and I may be speaking just personally
because this is what I look out out of
my bedroom window those dry stone walls
yes
the Lambs in the spring yes the mosaic
of different fields yes the Neolithic
standing stones yes the remnants of the
Roman occupation but above all a sense
of thousands of years of our own
identity it's not simply that 40% of
Lake District farmers carry Viking DNA
in their veins it's that those pollarded
ash trees in Borradaile were pollarded
first by the Vikings there's very little
of that left in Britain we've lost it in
the lowland by and large and
unfortunately in the Highlands of
Scotland we've lost it almost entirely
and I speak as somebody who comes from
the highlands of Scotland right I come
from an area that looks at valleys which
were once populated by small farms of
exactly the sort that you can see today
in the Lake District you can see the
remains of the dry stone walls you can
see the abandoned farmsteads
you can see the loss of all the evidence
of pastoral and agricultural life we
only have it left in the uplands it's a
rare precious fragile survival as I said
something as precious to us as
Westminster Abbey should be something
that we should be conserving and
preserving which is why I beg you if you
are focusing on environmental projects
please focus on the Highlands of
Scotland where there are huge spaces for
pursuing exactly the restorations of the
Caledonian forest that George is talking
about an area where incidentally the
number of visitors going to see that
forest is about one fourteenth of the
number of visitors going to see those
lake district elephants and please
invest in the lone uns please restore as
they have a net those lowland areas rich
in biodiversity close to cities which
populations can visit which contain our
most precious species and allow that
last fragile rare element of our
national identity in the uplands to
survive for generations to come because
if you don't you can see today in New
Hampshire you can see today and the
Pyrenees what would happen if it's lost
once it's gone those Shepherds those
farms those dry stone walls are gone
forever thank you and now speaking now
you don't have to get up they come and
do it down here that's part of the rule
of the game you have to just be seated
not allowed to stand unless you really
choose okay there is a global context to
this debate which i think is important
to remind ourselves of and that is that
the rest of life on our planet is in
crisis we heard earlier this spring that
the northern white rhino has gone
extinct giraffes and lions which were
part of my childhood imaginative world
are now threatened with extinction 50%
of all wildlife populations on this
planet have did have gone in the last 40
years there are 7.5 billion human beings
four-fifths of the Seas of the fished
areas of the sea are now fished to or
beyond their capacity in Europe alone we
lost 200 million pairs of breeding birds
we are in a real crisis and and we have
been very bad at valuing the rest of
life we are coming to
appreciate it and we've had a knock
about occasion tonight we've had some
fun but the truth is that really what I
found was a kind of consensual from all
sides that we need to change so we've
got Michael Gove here tonight and it is
a fantastic opportunity regardless of
whether weary wild the uplands vote for
it because we have to vote for a
fundamentally different way with our
relationship with the rest of life so I
ask you to vote for it to send a signal
regardless of the arguments themselves
because of that is the most powerful
thing
the audience can do well we can go into
them you can hear the knob out but we
need more nature the uplands are a
fantastic place to start I okay to vote
for this motion
and now the final words against the
motion Minette batters well regardless
of the argument tonight mark you just
said I think the argument is is
everything tonight and you talked of
giraffes and rhinos I'm not sure what
they hold place they hold in the uplands
I want to remind you of what I said
about the hasta broaden project in
Holland it started as a nice idea it
started with their debate very much like
this and it not only destroyed lives and
led to very long and protracted deaths
it has also made the Dutch government
come out and insists that within the
twenty the next 12 months the 50% of
those animals are cold so be very very
careful tonight about the decision that
you make because that was a nice idea
that went very very badly wrong now I do
definitely feel very much the odd one
out I think we've ascertained that I can
carve a cow I can save a lambs life I
can do many things that my fellow
panelists can't do I haven't written the
book and I can't probably speak as well
as they do but I can speak up
passionately with enormous pride for the
people that aren't here tonight that I
could count on one hand when I know that
there are 6,500 upland farmers in
England alone I also know and I want to
finish by reading one paragraph if you
haven't read this book please read it
James Reed banks the days when we walk
the sheep back to the fell are the best
moments of my year there is nothing like
the feeling of freedom and space that
you get when you are working with the
flock and the dogs on the common land we
can do this differently this is not
about harping back to the past this is
about building a new relationship with
agriculture and nature this
is about planting more cheese this is
about farmers role in mitigating climate
change this is about producing nutrient
high welfare healthy safe food we are an
island nation is 65 million people vote
for the farmers tonight they will rise
to the challenge
give them the chance please vote for
farmers and oppose the motion that is
put by two people that were the best
will in the world their incomes are
reliant on writing Armageddon stories
that attract ok great sound
and now finally for the motion
George mami oh well it was very decent
of Rory to call for the Highlands of
Scotland to be rewarded he might have
forgotten that they number among the
uplands of Britain so I would like to
thank him I would like to thank him for
conceding the motion now look I don't
object at all to people farming sheep if
they want to farm sheep it's a free
country let people farm sheep I do
object to paying for it I do object to
paying for the environmental harm that
it causes now post brexit when we lose
the European subsidies we're going to
have to make some pretty hard decisions
about what we are going to fund are we
going to spend 3 billion on continuing
the subsidy system given that that
equates to the NHS deficit or are we
going to use it to plug the nhf deficit
are we going to start spending money for
environmental restoration in places
where it makes sense to actually
Commission public goods rather than
public harms in terms of both ecological
restoration and economic restoration we
can hear the scare stories Minette
plucks out this one case of austere
vardoz plasm but there are scores of
fantastic highly successful rewilding
projects around Europe which are working
ecologic Lee working socially working
economically bringing back people onto
the land
and ladies and gentlemen ladies and
gentlemen the one thing they have not
addressed is how they're going to
sustain their vision which is a vision
rooted in the past of keeping farmers on
the fells given that the incomes are
already collapsing with subsidies are
they gonna herd them onto the land at
gunpoint and force them to keep sheep by
contrast what I'm putting forward is a
vision which can take place without
subsidies without Duras without going
back to a romantic imagined past but to
a glowing future a future which is
richer for people and richer for
wildlife thank you
and now I can give you the final votes
you will remember before when you came
in 61% were for the motion 13% were
against the motion
26 percent were undecided after the
debate 52 percent were for the motion
39% were against and 9 percent were
undecided which is a swing against the
proposers of the motion or of their
argument of 18 percent that's the
outcome my job now is simply to say
thank you I thought I'm sure you did too
that every one minute spoke with
eloquence passion demonstrating the
extreme importance to everyone involved
of this massively significant debate so
thank you George mombi Aurora Stuart
mark Crocker and the net battles
[Applause]
and finally on all over hearts on all
over house thank you yet again to
intelligence squared good night